number five finally this video that i'll
play now uh almost got itself on the
daily cancellation it was very close it
was a near tie
almost got there this is from the media
outlet now this which puts out horrible
cringy stuff all the time but this
may be worse than anything else they've
put out the title is most americans got
smaller tax refunds in 2019
thanks to donald trump listen to this
my refund was about half of what it
normally is we were really banking on
the refund
i called my husband immediately crying
[Music]
so i went back in and i checked
everything and then
i started to cry this year i just don't
have a refund
[Music]
my refund was about half of what it
normally is it used to be like 4 000 and
then i got 2 000 this year
[Music]
but this year instead of getting back
the five thousand dollars right was
expecting and that she and her husband
got last year
the houston mom found they actually owed
the government money
with the birth of new daughter olivia
just three weeks ago
wright says her family was counting on a
tax refund
to cover the cost of her unpaid
maternity leave we were really banking
on the refund because we
you know we love paycheck to paycheck we
can't in a sense
save as of right now with three kids in
college the edmy family is now
scrambling
last year they got a ten thousand dollar
refund but because of high property
taxes
this year they owe ten thousand dollars
okay stop stop it again
make it stop just make it stop i mean it
actually says in the video on the screen
it explains it admits that in most cases
people didn't get a refund because they
paid less in taxes
and had more money in their paychecks
yet
we're still getting this tearful
sorrowful complaining video
um so why do they get less
in the refunds because refunds aren't
bonus checks
that's not what they are my god
if you got a lower refund that's a good
thing it means you
paid less in taxes it means you kept
more of your own money a refund is just
the government returning the money it
took from you
as a no interest loan it's better to not
give a no interest loan if you could
choose between giving a no interest loan
or not giving a no interest loan
financially there is no benefit
whatsoever to the no interest loan
loaning the government money and
receiving it back with no interest
there's no benefit to you
it is better to keep your own money 100
percent
you could invest that money in a million
different ways
or spend it waste it whatever you're
gonna do and that's what most people do
with their tax refunds anyway they just
wasted on on crap
um but you could do that with your
paycheck i mean it's
it's there's no advantage really no
financial advantage
now i look i understand the
psychological advantage the
psychological boon
of getting a check in the mail certainly
feels a lot better than mailing one
a refund sort of feels like it's
equivalent to
finding money in the couch cushions
right it feels like
free money but it's not
okay and intentionally trying to make it
so that you get a refund
is like purposefully stashing wads of
cash in the in the couch for the thrill
of finding it later
it's it's one thing to go oh cool five
bucks didn't realize i had this when you
pull it out of the couch cushions that's
fine
but taking five dollars and putting it
under the kitchen
as an investment strategy is psychotic
and that's what people do with
withholding they they want they
they withhold more because they want the
refund
just put it in a savings account i mean
you'll get interest that was not a lot
of interest but it's more than you'll
get from the government
have you ever heard of a bank account i
hate some people all the time
they actually tell me they withhold more
so that they get a refund
have you ever heard of a bank that's
what they're for
stop giving the government money for no
reason
this is why we need i i i'm not going to
go off on my uh
withholding thing again but this is why
we need to this is why we need to
abolish withholding
the whole withholding system it'll never
be abolished because it's so convenient
for the guy i mean
it's it's made people happy about paying
taxes
tax day has turned into a happy day for
a lot of people which it shouldn't be
but that's the dastardly strategy behind
the withholding system
hey you uh yeah you you're right you
right there
hit the subscribe button right now do it
do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it's
somewhat appreciated